this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Chris thanks for everybody for
being here so we're gonna talk about
berries now and most people like berries
which is of course a good thing I don't
have to
generally convince people to eat them
unlike some of the other products that
maybe somebody else might have been
talking about recently
so the berry breeding program at Cornell
has been around for a long time it was
one of the first breeding programs at
our station so I'm at the New York State
Agricultural Station Experiment Station
in Geneva a lot of people don't even
know we exist which is something that's
nice to tell people that were there
we've been there for a very long time
and berries have always been a part of
that program and our program is it's the
oldest breeding program in North America
we're pretty sure it's the oldest one in
the world but it's kind of hard to tell
sometimes when you get into the record
so we've been doing this for a long time
and we're pretty much that's when you
look at the other breeding programs
around the world and you look at their
records we're kind of our varieties of
foundational varieties all across the
world in other breeding programs as well
we primarily work in raspberry and
strawberry raspberry comes in a lot of
different colors that most people don't
know so of course red raspberries what
most people are familiar with but they
also come in black and purple and yellow
and blush and we've released varieties
in all of these colors over the years
some of the varieties you see in the
marketplace you wouldn't recognize why
because berries aren't sold by name
they're sold by name to the grower but
not to the consumer so a lot of people
don't even know that there are different
varieties if you go to the supermarket
what do you see you generally see big
red strawberry big red raspberries and
you don't realize because you don't see
varieties compared to each other
generally if you see differences in the
supermarket's organic and traditional or
conventional varieties are different
varieties usually and so maybe you can
tell the difference but normally you
can't tell the difference and the
industry has worked
hard to make it so because informing
consumers that every week is a new
variety it's very challenging it's the
same in strawberry so strawberries are
very regionally adapted so the varieties
that grow in California don't grow well
here the ones in Florida don't grow well
here are varieties don't grow well in
Southern California and you think about
the vast differences in climate you can
imagine that maybe these you know we
don't see the same trees growing in
different places will vary too the same
way you have to have varieties that are
adapted to where you live and where you
the climate and soils that you have
we've done a little bit with
blackberries and we're doing more with
blackberries because there is growing
availability and growing demand for
people to have blackberries and the
local market has been very sketchy for
us because of winter blackberries are
not particularly winter hardy and so now
we're working on varieties that can grow
in New York so that we can have local
blackberries as well most people don't
think New York when they think
strawberries four six in California
which of course 95% of the strawberries
in the US come from California but the
Northeast is the biggest region for very
consumption when you talk to companies
like Driscoll's the Northeast is their
market they love to sell in an or thesis
people like berries and they eat a lot
of them but that's at least four days
like truck to get here so the berries in
New York for strawberry start right now
so if you're interested in getting fresh
local strawberries now is the time to
start going to the farmers market they
are the first fruit to hit the market so
growers it's really important for
growers in New York they start getting
people to come out to the farms to come
to the stands to see some fresh product
and of course strawberries a trail of
strawberries right so it's a great way
to start the summer in New York
strawberries are the third leading fruit
crop so it is an important crops for
farmers in New York as well nationwide
were the sixth leading producer of
strawberries of course California
produces about five times more than the
rest of the country combined so six is
still a little bit down but California
has
much peaked in their production acreages
actually started to go down because they
just don't have any more space for
strawberries there's some labor issues
so we are looking for the possibility of
growing more strawberries in other parts
of the country including the Northeast
as strawberries do very well here
they're native there are strawberries
that grow while people have a tradition
of growing while are collecting wild
strawberries and raspberries of course
they're very small so it's a little
better to get them from a farmer so you
can pick them a little easier so of
course in the supermarket you have big
red raspberries big red strawberries of
course I have an interest in producing
big red ones as well this is one of our
varieties that is a big red raspberry
prince and giant fruit size and some of
these can and can be the size of a small
strawberry which is unusual but it's
really nice for pictures because it
fills containers really fast
people don't understand this as well so
berries are what are called filled
packed the berries you get in the
container in the supermarket we're put
in the container by the person who
picked it from the plant and no one else
touches it after that so how fast you
can get them into the container really
makes a difference for both the picker
and for the grower because they don't
have to pay as much to get them
harvested so of course we like big red
ones but competing with California big
red berries is most likely gonna be a
losing proposition their climate is so
perfect for growing berries that we need
to have some way to distinguish
ourselves from the California berries
you see in the supermarket and how we do
that generally is with flavor and
quality so this is our again another big
red berry but this is our Archer
strawberry that came out last year what
we find it's a little bit softer than
what you get in the supermarket because
we don't have to drive for days in a
semi to get it to market and that makes
a big difference both in quality and in
flavor because we can pick them much
riper and they don't have to be so firm
I get a lot of complaints people tell me
oh the strawberries in the supermarket
they're so hard they don't taste like
anything
that's part of the modern system of if
you want to drive it across the country
from central Mexico in December you've
got to have some firmness to get it
there and so we develop varieties that
are not that firm they're a little
juicier you have more flavor and they
can get to market in the same day often
so they really are very fresh and so our
growers can differentiate themselves by
having a product that tastes better and
my colleagues at Driscoll's that I know
very well some of them actually are my
student former students they tell me in
the Northeast when June berries or
strawberries are coming in June in New
York their sales go down and that is
their peak season as well and if a
company like Driscoll's can notice that
people are buying local produce it
really it does open their eyes and
they're you know the market is there
because people are interested in having
a good quality product that is locally
grown one of the things we're doing is
working with protected agriculture so
you can see on the top are what we call
high tunnels these are about twelve to
fourteen feet high on the bottom we call
low tunnels they go over the strawberry
plant it's just to keep the rain off so
a raspberry plant a raspberry fruit
that's been rained on lasts about a day
to two days and you're in your
refrigerator because it has absorbed
some of that water and really softened a
raspberry that's never been rained on
can last seven to ten days in your suit
in your refrigerator so the difference
between two days and seven days is huge
when you're talking to shelf-life or a
product so just keeping the plants dry
and keeping the fruit dry it's a big big
advantage of course this year as the
rains have not stopped for us for the
most part it really has made a big
difference and we've just started
harvesting strawberries and normally in
a year like this when they've been
rained on 10 or 15 times bungle bungle
load gets really high the strawberries
are nice and dry under there
they're clean we haven't had to spray
fungicides and so everything it's
looking really good so this is one of
the things we've worked with my
colleague Marvin Pritz has also worked
on this quite a bit to show growers in
New York that we can grow strawberries
and raspberries and very high-quality by
doing some production practices
a little different than that we're used
to pretty much even in California the
raspberries are grown under tunnels to
keep them dry and so now with this kind
of technology we can have fresh berries
in New York somewhere being grown from
about mid-may until mid-november to
early December and people don't realize
that you can continue to get local
berries well into the fall and some of
the growers actually have problems
people don't believe them they're
picking raspberries in October and
they're putting them on the market and
they they can't believe that they
actually came from the local field and
they have to educate the grower there or
the consumer and show them pictures of
the field hood and the fruit being
picked raspberries are an interesting
crop because big and red is what you see
in the supermarket but what we would
like to do and what we're starting to do
is expand that palette to get people to
think about raspberries beyond that the
industry has been focused much more in
the last 10 to 15 years on having them
available all the time pretty much now
though you go to the supermarket
strawberries raspberries blackberries
blueberries they're there all the time
year-round and now's the time where we
can expand that and start giving people
some different choices the big red ones
are always going to be there so now
let's look at specialty ones that come
around seasonally ones that taste a
little different of course there's
yellow blush black purple like I was
saying and we have varieties like that
and some of the flavors and those are
just outstanding right now where you're
going to find those are in the local
markets because some of the growers want
to differentiate themselves now from the
other local growers and have a product
that's a little different so we've
developed a few varieties in recent
years for crimson night were - - that
dark red color you can imagine the juice
and jam that you make out of something
like this it's really outstanding the
frozen product there is a really nice it
has a really sweet flavor the blush one
we call that apricot in the breeding
world but the best-tasting raspberry
that I have it really is confuses people
because it never turns red when you
freeze it it turns pink it's very
interesting variety but it's really
interesting to the growers as well
because even if people don't buy it they
come over to their market just to see it
or to try it and then they might just
buy red ones but it starts a
conversation with the grower and the
consumer so they can start to learn
about this and we see this very
interesting to the the gardening world
the home gardener as well because they
know more about it because they've been
growing it themselves and you know I
grew up on a farm where we always had a
garden and gardeners like to brag to
each other about whatever it is they
have that their neighbor doesn't have
and so this kind of stuff really brings
a conversation about what they might be
growing so this is our we have a purple
strawberry as well it ripens to a red
wine color the juice is just as dark as
you see on the outside we're selling
that to Burpee because the homeowners
are really interested something
different and the flavor on that is just
just outstanding you won't see that in a
supermarket probably for a while because
nobody knows how to market it exactly
but but the home gardener already knows
because they know what tastes good and
so that's what they're looking for now
people don't realize that strawberries
can come in other colors there's white
strawberries as well or starting to see
those in the marketplace a little bit
this is a pine berry type you might see
that occasionally if you ever go on
YouTube and look at white strawberries
in Japan you'll be amazed at what
they're doing it's it's a little it's a
little crazy they're selling them
individually individual berries and
they're packed in a nice soft container
and they sell them as gifts and special
occasions it's pretty wild what they're
what what people will do if they have
too much money on their hand but growers
are looking to sell and make money so
you know what if you can have a
specialty product why not
and with that conclude again I will tell
you now is the time to get your
strawberry so get to the local markets
and I think you'll be really really
pleased with what what you can get
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu